les migrants disparu en méditerranée
c'est une thématique récurrente dans les
jt depuis les années 90 à moins de 100
mètres de là des tombes anonymes les
courants du détroit de gibraltar ne
pardonne pas déjà 300 noyer et ce n'est
pas fini
dès 1993 des associations et ong tentent
de comptabiliser les morts et disparus
en méditerranée
l'organisation united par exemple
recense les corps retrouvés sur les
plages et les disparitions rapportés par
les rescapés
selon son décompte non exhaustif
le nombre de morts annuelle est passée
de 62 en 1993 à 1254 en 2009 même s'il y
a des morts ça ne s'arrêtera jamais
chacun sa chance 2011 le début de la
guerre en syrie le nombre de morts ou
disparus en méditerranée a explosé
depuis la crise migratoire atteint des
sommets une photo la symbolise celle du
petit taylan curdy échoué sur une plage
turc
la photo du petit enfant syrien fait la
une de la presse mondiale en 2015
les vagues étaient si haute
maintenant que le bateau s'est retourné
dans les registres de l'onu l'année 2016
devient un triste record 5096 morts ou
disparus ont été dénombrés c'est cette
même année que sos méditerranée a lancé
sa mission à bord de l'aquarius pour
sauver les naufragés
à bord des médecins des sauveteurs et
des secouristes des volontaires ces gens
qui sont
qui sont en difficulté on va pas juste
les regarder mourir à la télévision et
on est vraiment là pour les sortir de
l'eau entre 2016 et fin 2018 l'aquarius
revendiquait 30 mille sauvetage dans le
même temps dits 1500 disparus ont été
recensés dans les eaux de la
méditerranée
[Musique]